each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
we're alive if you were listening before
you might have heard that Professor
Clark is from the University of
Washington where he actually is in
department of sociology and is a
sociologist and is making extensive use
of tools like sequel server in i would
say fairly non-traditional ways in
particular doing social science
simulation that model various kinds of
policy interventions in fairly important
issues issues like the transmission of
AIDS so with that I'd like to hand it
over to Professor Clark and I hope you
will join me in welcoming him here today
thank you great thank you the title of
my talk today is relational databases in
the Social and Health Sciences the view
from demography and I'm going to start
with just a brief introduction of myself
I was born and grew up in East Africa
and that will help you understand why I
have such a focus on Africa and the work
that I do I was trained as an undergrad
at Caltech in biology and engineering
and applied sciences most of the biology
training was in neurosciences and most
of the engineering in computer science
so I have a little bit of background
there then I went to graduate school
that pendant did a PhD in demography so
that's where the social science
component comes in i'm currently at the
university of washington and my main
interests are african demography which
is the structure and dynamics of
populations in my case looking
specifically in Africa modeling the
impact of HIV in African populations and
developing data management methods for
tracking human populations with
particular interest in health issues so
this is a summary of my talk I'm glad
you all showed up by the way thank you
very much I'm used to talking to
academics students and complete lay
people and I didn't quite know what this
is expect here today so I have a variety
of things I'm going to tell you a little
bit about some of the work modeling and
simulating populations that I've done
that work uses
both access and sequel server so it
touches on your environment a little bit
I'm going to talk about longitudinal
studies in the developing world health
and social studies these studies use all
kinds of data management tools in
particular sequel server and I've spent
a lot of time thinking about how to to
better use relational databases in those
environments then I'll talk briefly
about archiving and management of social
science data data analysis and mining in
the social sciences and finally
education and training and then a little
bit of a fantasy about what we would
like to see happening okay so starting
with modeling and simulation effectively
what I want to do is model an entire
population and use this model as a
heuristic tool to help me understand how
the whole system functions in other
words how all the pieces at various
levels are interacting with each other
all the way from sub individual that is
cells all the way up through the
population so we have salespeople
population I'm not trying to be accurate
in terms of reproducing any given
population but rather use the whole
thing as a virtual sandbox in which I
can study the system so the idea is to
create a whole population through time
with realistic demography and that
includes the vital dynamics the birth
and death of individual people and good
marriage dynamics who's hooking up with
who and what are they doing are they
having kids are they not having kids how
quickly do they have them and so forth
and then finally adding HIV at the
individual level so that we have a
within individual incubation of the
disease if you get infected you go
through the first part of the disease is
relatively asymptomatic and then toward
the end you get AIDS you get real sick
you start behaving very differently and
you die to do this we have to have
transmission both horizontal between
adults through normal heterosexual sex
in Africa that's the predominant mode of
transmission and then vertical
transmission which is from a mother to
her child then that can happen through
the birth process itself or through
breastfeeding and then finally the
interesting bit modeling interventions
that do something to to a
this whole system ok so the tool that I
developed is a structured population of
n history simulator it's an individual
level stochastic to sex simulator so it
models all those things that I just
described in addition to polygynous
marriage that is multiple women per man
and in lots of African settings you have
marriages that are this way more than
one woman / man very important when
you're talking about sexually
transmitted diseases to take into
account the non-sanctioned relationships
that exist so those are non marital
relationships and then of course we have
to have the disease progression at the
individual level which reflects the
person's trajectory through an HIV
illness let's see how do we get this to
go Larry there we go okay so this is the
bit that we can talk a lot more about if
anyone is interested the entire
simulator is built around a relational
database that both generates and manages
the data that are simulated now
surprising to almost everyone will be
the fact that it's ms access 97 and this
is because I I started this work I think
in about ninety eight it took me about
three years to build at the time I
didn't have either the time or the
resources to really learn an
enterprise-level are DBMS 97 was there
it turns out to be pretty handy and it's
it's not the fastest thing in the world
but it actually it actually does this so
I use Visual Basic for applications and
the SQL that is implemented in in 97 to
execute all the logic associated with
the simulator it generates full
histories and records those histories
for every individual so that I can go
back and analyze the interaction of
individuals over an entire simulated
period something that's very nice and is
different from a lot of other modeling
strategies as these simulations can be
stopped and restarted so you can
simulate a bunch of years you can stop
that change parameter values do a bunch
of things and then start it up again and
obviously it can take both time varying
and constant parameters and you can also
generate parameters on the
fly things like the prevalence of HIV
and then feed those back into the
dynamics of the of the simulation the
core data model is right here you can
see it's a pretty simple thing we have
people here we have unions both marital
and non-marital here we have lengths
between people and unions that can be
the spouses and the children produced by
the Union we have fertility events right
there in the middle these track the
fertility history of each woman
conceptions miscarriages births end of
breastfeeding and so on these are
pregnancies that have to be tracked in
order to take into account the effect of
HIV on pregnancy and the fact that it
reduces the ability of women to carry
fetus to term which it obviously impacts
on fertility a lot that's the core data
model there about 100 other tables in
this database that manage the parameters
and then the the outputs from the model
but the real core is just that simple so
they're a bunch of dinah modules here to
govern dynamics we have a fertility
module a mortality module two modules
that deal with marriage one that deals
with regular marriage one that deals
with non-marital unions a very important
module at the bottom is sexual
intercourse the model generates sexual
intercourse events that lead to both
conceptions and the transmission of
disease and HIV affects fertility and a
lot of the interventions that affect HIV
also affect fertility for instance
condoms if you enter if you intervene
with condoms you have a big impact on
the transmission of sexually transmitted
diseases you also prevent a lot of
births if you don't take all of that
into account simultaneously you wind up
with a model that doesn't reproduce what
actually happens and then finally
there's a module 2 to deal with HIV the
timescale here is one month so we're
dealing with a time granularity of a
month for sex with you all the time
granularity of one day and cumulated
over a month I just went over that these
are some details on the HIV module
parameters a simulator of this story
takes a lot of data to per
motorized it to actually feed in all of
the rates with which people do things
have sex get married get divorced
whether or not having two kids affects
your divorce rate versus three four and
so on all of that data comes from a very
detailed forty year study of a
population in southern Zambia where
they've tracked 10,000 people for 40
years and literally kept track of
everything so I had very rich data to
parametrize this except for the
non-marital unions and have you can
expect not very many people are willing
to openly discuss what they're doing
extra curricular we have some vague
information about this now we actually
have so much better information but when
I did this we didn't and effectively I
made this up and I generated those
parameters so that the entire thing
reproduced the broad demographic
behavior of the population for instance
the growth rate the fertility rate and
the mortality rate pretty much matched
match reality even with these things in
there and then finally HIV impact
there's lots of good measurements of
what HIV does to individual people in
two populations calibrating it these are
the things I matched overall growth rate
sex ratio fraction married fertility
mortality and up she ality so those
things in the simulator match the same
things in the Zambian population from
which the parameters come okay now i
have two examples of studies that have
resulted from running the simulator two
questions that i looked at and i'm going
to skip over these right now and move to
a couple other topics and maybe come
back if we have time so I'm going to
switch gears here a little bit and tell
you about a couple other modeling
exercises in the kind of Social and
Health Sciences world that use
specifically use sequel server actually
as the underlying enabling technology
the first here is the actuarial society
of South Africa's aids model is called
the Assam model somewhat unfortunate
acronym but there it is this is a very
important model in the Southern African
context it's used to model the entire
population in South Africa
it uses a cohort component projection
framework which breaks down the
population by age and by sex and in this
case also by geographic region and by
race and then further by behavioral
category people who are pretty much
hetero hetero sexual and faithful people
who have a lot of partners prostitutes
and commercial sex workers of various
sorts and so on the idea is that we're
able to project the entire population of
South Africa into the future predict the
number of people who are going to be HIV
positive predict the number of HIV AIDS
related deaths predict the number of
kids who are going to be infected
predict the age structure of all of
these things and feed all of this back
into the people who have to make
decisions about how much care needs to
be provided who needs to get it where it
needs to be provided and so on the
original model was actually implemented
in Excel and when you hit run it took a
while it still takes about six minutes
for a run then there's a version which
is written in C++ which takes a very
small fraction of a second to run the
whole thing and when you can run it in a
fraction of a second what you're tempted
to do is running hundreds of thousands
or millions of times with lots of
variations so that you can study
uncertainty in the in the results and
when you do that you end up with a
tremendous amount of data that you've
generated and then you need a database
to store all that stuff and sift through
it so sequel server is now being used as
the backend to manage both the
parameters and the results of those
those model runs if anyone's interested
there's the link to go look at that
model you can download the excel version
another much more high-profile
population related institution is the
UN's Population division in New York
they have a model which they called
abacus dim don't ask me why but this is
the name of the model it's another
cohort component projection model does
essentially the same thing as the acid
model except they have to do this for
every single country in the world every
two years they have to produce hundred
year project
so they have a very large amount of data
that they need to manage in terms of
parameters for those in terms of
predictions that they make they have to
do actual forecast so they have to have
a high medium and low for every country
for a hundred years and then they have
to publish all of this stuff and they
have to add it to their backlog of
archived projections which they then
compare themselves to as time goes into
the future so they've been doing this
for a long time on mainframes using
COBOL and things like that and recently
within the last two years I think they
have switched entirely to using sequel
server to manage the data and VB to
actually execute the logic of the model
and as far as I know they're extremely
happy with that that kind of
architecture ok now another switch in in
topic now we're going to look at
longitudinal studies and instead of
looking at generating data and modeling
processes we're going to look at
collecting data real data and storing it
and analyzing it so longitudinal studies
are probably more familiar to us
temporal these are studies that span a
long period of time and they're very
common in the population health sciences
examples are demographic surveillance
panel studies repeated linked
cross-sectional studies cohort studies
anything that follows the unit of
analysis through time all of these
involve observing units of analysis
usually individuals recording their
histories and often recording the
relationships between people over long
periods of time so the base the basic
idea is that you're able then to make
some kind of a statement about cause and
effect because you know at point a
condition X prevailed and a period of
time later something happened and you
can relate those two things to each
other okay the data data management
requirements are interesting these
studies produce large amounts of complex
temporal data they often lasts for
periods of decades which means several
interesting things happen technologies
change radically so what you started
with in terms of a data management
technology is not what you you
available now so you have legacy data
issues that are sometimes very serious
in addition to that the requirements of
the studies change so you may have
started out as a vitamin a trial in
Ghana and now you're doing HIV vaccine
trials so the the substantive nature of
what you're doing is also completely
different and a lot of these studies
right now are being developed and
generated in the developing world where
the overall infrastructure for managing
data is poor the basic IT infrastructure
is not so great bandwidth is very low
and so on so there's a big challenge
involved here both in terms of how to
manage this data and increasingly where
it's managed hello I hope wishes what
exactly Oh Hodges much how large is
large these range from about 10,000
people two maybe three hundred thousand
people some of them are only two years
old some of them are 40 years old some
of them are 60 years old so if you have
200,000 people that you visit say every
two weeks for 60 years you have a large
data set it's in a well normalized form
it can be a gigabytes sighs you know
several gigabytes if you do that in a
nun normalized data model I mean it can
be hundreds of gigabytes even small data
data sets that Miss Lee monitor 10,000
people over five years if you don't have
it in a well normalized data model can
be many many gigabytes the observational
simulation data sets must be worse
magnet I guess one of the issues I think
I'm carrying is multiple gigabytes is
not work yes for you guys but the
simulation models must generate heroines
they could easily generate terabytes
usually people don't keep terabytes this
is the prom this is one of the big
problems okay so this is this is
something I wanted to to bring up a
little bit later is that there's a
fundamental disconnect between basic IT
professionals like some of you are
and most of us who are working in the
social sciences I'd say we're at least
two or three decades behind where I t
technology actually is most of my
colleagues would think that a 500
megabyte data set is big unmanageably
big in some cases so anyway we'll get to
that in a minute so we have data models
and standards for one type of of this
data the so-called demographic
surveillance system data then you see
yes here we are so I'm just going to
talk a little bit about what exists in
the field brightness art yes like then
you make this statement that you don't
have a solution what exactly do you mean
what I mean how is it like what's an
office your phone is it like simply that
define a database all after you
outnumber the data once you have a
diameter is like putting it to use in
some this is most people can put the
data into a database the problem begins
to make itself known after the day to
get into the database the number one
issue is that the databases are not
structured in a consistent way so
there's no standard in terms of how the
data are structured is also no standard
in terms of the semantics of the data
data similar data are defined
differently so it's fine for the one
study those guys can manage kind of
manage their own data they can kind of
analyze it and deal with it what people
want to do increasingly is pool these
data put them together say combine data
from a site in India aside in Bangladesh
a site in Nepal and say something about
the Indian subcontinent and the way the
way they're structured right now these
data are very difficult to work with and
do something like that so what we're
talking about is pretty much from the
data input step onward thinking through
much more systematically developing
standards and developing software
systems that people could essentially
use off the shelf and do what they need
to do here what's happening is
everybody's developing their own system
so everything is developed in an ad hoc
idiosyncratic way by local developers
who have very
degrees of of ability background
education and so on and it's basically a
big mess is another dimension of that
the fact that it's only recently that
there's a migration to oh he would
consider the search state-of-the-art
yeah and the migration hasn't even
started in a lot of cases and people are
still using V base some people are still
using text files some people manage
their data and statistical packages not
databases at all so part of the idea is
bringing everybody at least into the
into the realm of the modern data
management okay so I'm going to tell you
a little bit about the state of the art
here and I'm going to use the
demographic surveillance system as the
the organizing principle there's
something called the reference data
model which was developed by four
colleagues and myself in 1998 none of us
having any real training in relational
database design and we put together this
data model that would be able to manage
the basic elements of a demographic
surveillance system which are birth
death marriage divorce and migration if
the reasonable little data model it has
been incorporated into something called
the household registration system which
is the de facto software that people use
for demographic surveillance in
retrospect it's a very bad design we
didn't know we were doing it's a it's
absolutely fixed there's no metadata
layer it's totally unfold in terms of
its relational structures is bad it's
relatively simple everybody who uses it
has to modify it so basically they have
to break down the the code it's an
open-source things everybody can tinker
with it everybody tinkers with it does
something slightly different makes it
incompatible with their neighbor and
moves on it's also implemented in
Foxborough and I don't know what you
guys think about foxpro but my personal
opinion is that it has limits pretty
serious limits in terms of the quantity
of data that it can manage and how well
it does doing that mm-hmm so we're
trying to get people to get out of
foxpro but many people are still stuck
there
ok now I'm going to talk about one thing
here so the structured population event
history register is our first attempt to
be more systematic about this and design
some core concepts for a data model that
would do a better job so here I'm going
to tell you a little bit about
demographics surveillance a little bit
more than I have just now it monitors
the geographically defined population
for long periods of time records
everything to do with births deaths in
out migrations internal migration so we
keep track of people moving around
inside the area marriages and
separations and then in most cases
augments itself with a whole bunch of
other information related to health and
in social science so intervention trials
drug trials vaccine trials chronic
disease monitoring cause of death
investigations and you name it people
add new investigations to these DSS
sites and in terms of social science
people study things like the
relationship between economic indicators
and people's decision-making at the
household level so what happens to a
household when somebody dies of HIV
taking into account all of the streams
of income that that household might have
and all of the expenditures that they
might be dealing with okay so we need a
solution to manage all of these data
that are generated they're strongly
temporal the sites are long-lived
specifications change over time
technologies change over time and at the
moment no effective solution really
exists and like I said people are very
very interested in being able to pool
share and compare these data in fact I
know that they're not linked to you guys
but the Gates Foundation is has
solicited from us an application to
develop a system of this sort because
they see it as a key a key stumbling
block in terms of developing countries
ability to monitor the health of their
populations and develop in a timely
fashion new interventions okay so we
need something that's going to
effectively manage the SS data at single
sites and at many sites at the same time
and allow those data to be
standardized enough to be put together
analyzed together and quickly produce
some kind of a result ok so the existing
temporal frameworks are pretty much how
do we say there is a lot of theoretical
work in terms of temporal databases but
as any of you know who've worked with
relational databases not much of that
has actually seeped into the production
systems so all of this nice theoretical
work around interval based data pretty
much you don't find that functionality
in sequel server or Oracle or db2 or
anything else so we have the ideas
floating around out there we don't have
the the implementations that would be
really nice so we're struggling with
designing relational data models that
allow us to do some of that with the
tools that we actually do have so the
aim here is to present a general
conceptual framework to unify the
representation of time and structure of
the population okay so we want to
develop a temporal data model that's
general and hence flexible and
extensible so that it's going to have a
long life live for decades in these
sites maybe move through several
generations of relational database
management systems we want to try and
adhere to this idea of a metadata driven
data specification that can be updated
and extended without having to change
the underlying hard structure of the
data which would lead to something like
schema invariance and we need to be able
to accommodate and manage data from
multiple sites efficiently and provide a
means through which to rapidly implement
new data management modules so if we
have a metadata description of what we
need to do we can share that metadata
with other sites have them loaded up and
be able to manage those new data in
exactly the same way across lots of
sites okay so time I don't know if any
of you have really gotten into time it
turns into philosophy at a certain point
very rapidly it's Universal it's
one-dimensional it's dense unbounded
difficult to precisely conceptualize
measure and manipulate when we started
getting into this the colleague of mine
and
we we read a lot of physics papers about
astronomical time and real time and how
they interrelate and all kinds of stuff
essentially what we have to worry about
our two types of of time events that
mark changes between different states so
those are something that happens at a
very well-defined short duration period
of time and then states which are long
intervals between events during which
some constant state of being is
maintained and there are a few others
but those are the primary things where
we're interested in so the temporal
entities the states everything that we
want to consider in these DSS sites has
a valid lifetime so that makes them
states they have a well-defined
beginning well defined in and a constant
meaningful motor condition of being in
between and they can be either tangible
physical things like people or
intangible things like marital unions it
turns out you can generalize all kinds
of things into this idea of a state so
they are associated with everything
that's constant then we have the events
which bring about change and mark the
beginning in the ends of these states
and they occurred a well-defined point
in time bring about some change and the
change influences one or more states and
it's important here because events
influence lots of different states and
through their joint influence on many
states can encode the links between
states so the relationships that exist
between states so examples that we're
interested in our births deaths weddings
observations and movements and then the
third element of this idea is the
influence and it influences an explicit
representation of the link between a
state and the events that influence that
state so influences represent the
influence of a specific type of event on
a specific type of state and are linked
to exactly one state and one event and
together for many to many relationships
between events and states I think I'm
going to skip over this diagram
essentially here no maybe not what we
have here is a very simple example
population so we have in green saree the
laser
a bit I can't really see it there we go
so the green horizontal bars are States
the blue vertical bars are events and
the little red dots are the influences
so you can conceptualize this kind of
temporal system as things that are
persistent through time events that
change those conditions and links
between the events in the states coated
by those little red dots so in our
relational data model we are going to
have three basic tables one to store
each of those three elements okay so
that brings us to the structure
population event history register which
is a relational database schema that
implements this event influence state
concept and it's a very general idea can
be implemented in any relational
database and its metadata driven those
three things are very general in order
to specify specific events influences
and states you have to be able to have a
second layer of data which defines the
domain for each of those three things
and then you can form links between the
actual i want to say incarnations of the
general entities and the metadata that
described them so this gives you a very
flexible and relatively simple way of
recording the temporal evolution of a
connected population okay the metadata
are not new to you guys at all but are
very new for some reason to social
scientists in fact the word is totally
foreign I have to explain it to to to
those guys most of the time and it's an
important thing here because it gives us
the I'm not going to go through this in
detail essentially the metadata as we
all know give us a kind of malleable
description of what's going on and then
you can write routines that utilize that
metadata and and generate specific
actions based on the metadata so it's
it's nice and useful okay we'll skip
through those here's an actual schema
I've built a couple demonstration
databases that implement this
seemed to do a pretty good job I can
calculate all of the things that
normally need to be calculated and store
all kinds of different data in this one
schema without having to change the the
underlying structure just to touch on
the fact that if you follow it through
in detail this is a normalized data
model and in particular it's very
important from my point of view that the
timestamps appear in only one place that
is in the events table one of the big
stumbling blocks in these kinds of data
management systems is that dates get
distributed all over the place and as
time goes by people add new tables and
they put dates in those tables like a
date of birth or a date of death and
that same date exists in three other
tables in the database and when someone
goes to edit or update those dates they
remember one place or the developer
remembers to write a trigger that
updates three out of the four places and
over the course of a few years you wind
up with a database that's literally
totally unanalyzable from a temporal
point of view in fact I know several
projects that have just had to go back
and re-enter everything because it
unravels so badly so this is important
that the dates are in one place you
update them in one place and then
through the links they get reflected all
over the place we don't need to worry
about that because we now have a
standard data structure the metadata
allow us to have standard semantics for
our our primary data we have the ability
to share data very easily and also the
pool data very easily which is very
important to developing multi-site
studies and multi-site interventions ok
there's the multi-site idea there's
several things which are missing here
the first is metadata driven integrity
constraints especially around the
temporal entities in the data model and
you know referential integrity in
relational database is a
bread-and-butter thing temporal
integrity is not and especially being
able to enforce temporal integrity in a
normalized structure so we're still
working on that the other thing we want
to do is develop metadata driven
representations of questionnaires and
link those metadata and the data they
collect in the
database so in other words you have
something like a language which
describes the data input machine that
you use to acquire data from people in
our case it's usually a questionnaire so
you have the elements and you have the
layout we want to be able to store that
then go out and use it to collect data
and then store those data and store a
link between the data and the instrument
that collected the data in our case a
single question may change over time and
how people administer the question may
also change over time and that
influences how people answer the
question so I want to store all of that
together so that when someone goes to
analyze the data they can look at the
data then they can look at the question
that elicited the data see how that
changed over time control for whatever
biases may be introduced by that and
carry on we also want to be able to
present these data collection
instruments on pdas on paper and via an
HTML interface so we want to be able to
have the same representation manifested
in several different ways and give us
flexibility in terms of how the data are
input to the database and then one of
the biggest problems that we're facing
is once the data are all happy and
consistent in the database how do we get
them out and give them to analysts in a
way that they can do something with them
it turns out to be a huge problem again
because statisticians are usually not
trained in data management we can't give
them a relational database because
they're going to hack it up and they
don't know what to do with it so we have
to make flat files for them and we have
to make them in a very structured way
that can be fed into the statistical
packages that they use and analyzed well
the disconnect between the people who do
the SQL to get the data out and the
people who analyze the data is really
severe and the communication that
happens there is very poor usually
results in a multi round iterative
process where you request the data set
it's not right you request it again
maybe goes through ten iterations before
the person has the data set they like
it's a big waste of time because these
SQL programmers are expensive and scarce
and it's something we want to try to
address by developing automated kind of
wizard based ways of creating complex
and
analysis data files okay here's some
example databases okay now I'm just
going to run few through a few things
quite quickly the first is archiving and
management of large social science data
sets large and quotes again for you guys
there's something called the data
sharing for demographic research
initiative at the University of Michigan
there's a link there at the top to that
this is an initiative in response to
another initiative by the National
Institutes of Health who in 2003
published a comprehensive data sharing
policy anything any project that is
supported with public money through the
NIH has to make their data available in
a timely fashion to everyone and there
is a an actually large amount of data
produced by all of the projects that are
NIH funded and I have to say they are
better on average than most social
scientists the ones who run this data
sharing initiative but they're still not
completely I think up to the
up-to-the-minute in terms of Technology
and and practice and data management so
we still have a lot of linked flat files
with a lot of repetition we have trouble
getting data sets in a form that
analysts can use them they're very good
at cataloguing and documenting I'm not
sure that they're great at presenting
and allowing indexing allowing you to
search it anyway this is going on it's a
relatively big data store big storage
lots of data available there and
increasingly using relational databases
is something called the in-depth network
this is a network of dss sites
predominantly in the developing world
there are about 40 of them right now
mostly in Africa quite a few in Asia
several in Latin America and one or two
in Eastern Europe these sites have
identified this lack of a solution that
works for everybody as a major problem
and we're preparing a proposal to create
a new piece of software to try and
address this and that software will in
particular look at the capture of data
using both paper and PDAs particularly
wanting to look at PDAs for lots of
reasons reduced costs increasing quality
of data captured ability to capture
other kinds of information like GPS
coordinates biometric measurements and
so on oops trying to address issues of
data quality storage of manipulation
with a great emphasis on extraction and
analysis and then another big emphasis
on archiving taking all of the data and
making sure it gets into a searchable
electronic archive with links to the
original capture instruments the perhaps
the biggest requirement here is making
sure that we can share and pool the data
and that implies developing standards
which hopefully we're on the road to
doing but could probably use a lot more
work we're envisioning about 20 million
dollars necessary to do this and
hopefully we're going to get a
consortium of the Gates Foundation the
Wellcome Trust and the NIH to pay for
that we want to work with professional
software developers to develop the spec
that is and then hire a programming
house to do it as rapidly as possible
we're thinking two years three years so
20 million over three years yes okay so
that's not a prettier finger no no in
total but I I have a hunch that it's I
mean this is the ballpark at the very
front end of this process I think it's
going to grow and these these endeavors
have a very very dubious history the I
don't know if you know any of you are
familiar with the national health system
in the UK that has already spent I think
it's around 10 billion pounds on a
national hospital and clinic and patient
record management system which is
basically going down in flames right now
I know that HP was working on a big one
a while ago and I haven't heard anything
about that for a while
when not health but obviously another
population surveillance technology but
they just scrapped there's an artificer
again there are several hundreds of
kinds of hours exactly so it it seems
deceptively simple to to do this but the
the track record is that it's it's very
hard and we're amateurs we'll see what
happens but there is a clearly defined
need and there are a lot of very very
interested parties all of the
foundations the nih wh 0 un aids are all
very interested in trying to make this
happen and make it happen very quickly
because essentially all of those dollars
that you hear about being spent on HIV
and malaria and TB have to have some
evidence base to allocate them and the
evidence base is just remarkably thin
and people are really worried about that
i want to augment it rapidly okay data
analysis and mining in the social
sciences extraction of analytical data
sets from complex temporal databases is
difficult requires usually that you have
a pretty skilled SQL programmer pretty
skilled SQL programmers who are willing
to work for academic wages are pretty
rare so there's a big problem there it's
a big bottleneck for most of these
longitudinal projects and there are very
few people in social science who have
the skills and and kind of history with
relational databases to be able to do
this effectively themselves in fact I
know of exactly three people like that
I'm one of them and I have two
colleagues who I know who are actually
social scientists who can do well enough
with this to to do this kind of thing so
we need a number of things we need
standard standard data structures and
routines for analysis and most
importantly we need more people who are
trained in both the substantive area and
data management that is the theory of
relational databases and some SQL skills
okay data warehouses in the social
sciences they don't exist yeah you see
that as an issue for how you train
social scientists or you see it as an
issue or how the economy pays computer
scientists or it is what I see that's
that's an issue of both basically how
you train Social Sciences I think that's
the first issue and then the second
issue is how you pay social scientists
and maybe there needs to be I mean I
think if people are going to take on
board skills like this then maybe you
know we're just going to pay them more
everybody says they want this and now
we're at well I'm just beginning to get
to the point where i can talk to deans
and people who can actually make
decisions about money and what I'm
telling them is basically you've got to
pony up more dollars to compete with
industry okay so data warehouses this is
the technology which truly does not
exist in the social sciences as far as
I'm aware fa p I worked with SI p in
South Africa on a project which is
attempting to develop a data warehouse
for demographic surveillance and it's my
opinion there's no product yet and I'm
very skeptical about their ability to
produce one I think they've totally
underestimated the complexity of what
they're about to do and that's being
borne out by the fact that they're
floundering around now for the fifth
year with nothing nothing on the verge
of coming out okay so this is an area I
think that is just right for all kinds
of development and at least it's right
for making people aware that this area
of information science exists education
and training then what we're doing at
the moment we have a master's in field
epidemiology that we support at the
University of the Witwatersrand in
Johannesburg in South Africa and as part
of that we have a three-week module on
relational databases in SQL and I teach
that and we run people through the
relational model of data SQL common data
models for DSS and how to write SQL as
far as I know it's the only formal
database training module in the social
sciences
anywhere and it's actually in public
health I don't know if any that exists
in north american-based universities at
the u-dub that I know quite well there's
absolutely no training available in data
management in the social sciences l Swan
campus obviously you can get training
like this in in a computer science
department information science but
they're what they're going to do is take
you through relational calculus and all
kinds of theoretical things which people
in the social sciences don't need they
need to understand enough of it so they
can write good SQL and do the work that
they need to do perhaps design a little
database so in other words you can't
shoot a a statistics graduate student
over to computer science and have them
take the course over there it's
basically a waste of time so we need to
have a different kind of training that's
available to people in the insulin
Health Sciences down here we have in
health science we have informatics
classes which basically teach people how
to infer how to interface with existing
hospital management systems patient
record management systems and things
like that people are facing the same
they are people get trained over there
and how to use a GIS system ESRI or one
of the other ones usually if you ask
them to move out of that and then even
linked to our kinds of data you wind up
with the same kind of problems you have
to hire a programmer to help you and the
problem is these programmers many of
them are great they're kind of expensive
but they have no idea about the
substantive nature of what you're trying
to do so is it is truly hard to
communicate with them and get a product
in a reasonable period of time that's
satisfactory okay
what we need we need more education in
data management principles for
scientists and training and social
behavioral and medical sciences from
Microsoft it's great that we now have
these Express editions of sequel server
and visual studio in terms of making
things happen in the developing world we
need cost structures that are
appropriate for those places some of
these projects just can't afford sequel
server licenses so they use one of the
free products MySQL or whatever and I'm
not partisan here but what I don't like
about those systems is that they are not
well documented they're hard to use and
that's where you guys have a big
advantage I mean there some people may
argue about the quality of the
documentation but pretty much it is
documented and you can figure out how to
use it okay and then my point at the
bottom here is that we still need lots
of basic research on interval based data
temporal and spatial and implementation
and systematic principle methods of
managing such data in a normalized form
including regular automated integrity
constraints that would allow us to
automatically and regularly make sure
that things are sequenced in the right
way make sure that everybody's marriages
for instance happen within their
lifetime instead of overlapping at the
beginning or the end making sure that
people died after they're born all these
things are big problems and I would like
to see a database system where I could
implement checks like that just like I
do referential integrity where we could
set it up nicely have the DBMS check
those things automatically okay those
are my contacts so we're sitting at
four-thirty how are we doing for glue
time for Q a good time for Q&A I can
show you some results of simulation if
you'd like which are fairly interesting
okay let's go back and do that no mean
fqa
back about the non-intuitive
implications of various interventions
okay maybe that way there you go so here
we have also i'll try to run you very
quickly through 22 results from the
simulator so to cross all the t's dot
all the i's this is done with a
undergraduate student of mine jeff eaten
who did most of the actual grunt work
for this study this is just a
distribution map of the prevalence of
HIV in africa the vast majority of
hiv-positive people globally live in
africa and the vast majority of them
live in southern africa here that's just
to give us some perspective there are a
number of observational studies that
indicate that male circumcision can can
influence the risk of transmitting HIV
from males to females okay I sorry from
females to males so starting from this
point people have argued that it would
be a great thing to circumcise all the
men in southern Africa and there are
so-called circumcision Nazis who are
absolutely attached to this viewpoint
that this is the golden bullet to the
silver bullet whatever that'll solve the
HIV epidemic there is now recently a
well-designed well constructed well done
clinical trial in South Africa that has
shown that circumcision reduces the
female-to-male probability of
transmission by about sixty percent so
the adjusted relative risk is 0 point
397 circumcised two hundred eyes
randomly yes okay
it was a randomized yes my this requires
yes the blind part is that still in
there that should not be there you
definitely know when you're circumcised
so male circumcision as an HIV
intervention strategy we know now from
the clinical trial just one at the
moment that there is an individual level
effect the question now is whether or
not this effect would aggregate up at
the population level to have a
significant impact on an epidemic okay
and there are other details could you
actually do it is it socially acceptable
is it logistically possible to go out
and circumcised a whole bunch of guys
and so on the short answer to those
things is yes people appear to be
willing to be circumcised and it's about
20 bucks a pop and can be done in large
parts of southern Africa okay so the
real question is does it have a
population level effect so here's a
little quote by one of my colleagues and
he is poo-pooing that in fairly direct
language and let you read it for
yourself
so my question to you would you be happy
having your your wife or yourself using
a birth control strategy that was only
sixty percent effective would you do
that if you really didn't want to have a
kid no you wouldn't structures right i
mean there are some really just an
innocent others may have works i may
have exactly so here's the point the
questions are how many circumcision
decisions would you need to perform
before being able to substantially
decrease the prevalence of HIV in other
words have an impact on an epidemic what
is the impact of an intervention that
targets only adults and is there an
impact on females in the population
given that this intervention should
directly impact only males and in which
subpopulation of males is male
circumcision going to be most efficient
so what we're going to do is simulate a
bunch of different scenarios three
different age groups we circumcised at
birth or between the ages of 10 and 13
or between the ages of 18 and 24 and at
four different levels ten percent
circumcised 25% 50 and 75 we're assuming
here that a baseline seven percent of
men are circumcised which is a fairly
decent assumption in in southern Africa
so this is an additional 10 25 50 or 75
percent here's the HIV prevalence in a
control epidemic along the horizontal
axis from zero to 129 our years of the
simulated epidemic and this is HIV
prevalence that is the fraction of the
total population that's HIV positive at
the beginning of the epidemic you can
see this big upswing this is the females
and they plateau out here at a little
lesson well let's look about 22 percent
and the males at about 18 we won't go
into why the difference is there but
that is a real difference and has to do
the age difference between partners ok
here is the at Birth intervention we
have the control group 10 25 50 percent
saturation circumcising at birth
starting in year 30 of the epidemic we
started at your 30 because the epidemics
in southern Africa are all mature
epidemics at this point so there's no
point looking at what happens in the
beginning you can see that it takes a
while for any real effect to materialize
and then there's virtually no difference
between the control in the ten percent
group and there's only a relatively
modest reduction even for the 75% group
the reason it has this big lag that big
lag is about one generation because it
takes these guys from birth until they
become sexually active for any effect to
materialize and here the deal is that
sixty percent protection just isn't
enough to protect you over a long period
of time with a high number of cumulated
exposures okay so at most we're getting
a what is this about it 18 to about 13
about a five percent real magnitude
reduction in HIV prevalence okay so the
next question is does the male
circumcision intervention affect the
prevalence and incidence for women and
children or is it just for men so here
we have the female HIV prevalence with
the at Birth intervention it mirrors the
male effect almost exactly in that if
you think think it through that that's
how it should work if you have fewer
males infected they're producing fewer
secondary cases in the female population
you should get a reduction and it's of a
relatively similar magnitude again up
until about ten percent there's no
effect at all here's the vertical
transmission for kids with the app birth
intervention again there's a lag and a
very similar magnitude reducing the
probability of transmitting a virus from
the mother to the kid because the
mother's not infected at all in this
case most people would consider these
fairly disappointing results I think
people were looking for much much bigger
results okay and now what happens when
we initiate the intervention in
different age groups so does the
magnitude in the effect of the male
circumcision depend on which age we
circumcised
and does the age and circumcision affect
the time horizon of the impact and it
should as we as we know so here's the
teenage intervention again in year 30
and what we see is that we begin seeing
the impact of the intervention right
away and that's because we're
intervening with people who are just
becoming sexually active so that makes
sense the overall final impact is about
the same here's the whoops male agent
image male male HIV prevalence adult
intervention right so now we're only
interviewing with adults this is young
adults 18 to 24 and we have an immediate
impact and the final impact roughly the
same here's the prevalence prevented for
the fifty percent coverage for males so
we have the at Birth intervention in
solid blue the teen intervention in pink
in the adult intervention in yellow this
is the residual prevalence the control
minus the intervention so this is the
amount of of prevalence taken away by
the intervention you can see that for
the adult intervention it kicks in right
away goes up to about here and
stabilizes like that for the teenage
intervention it's it's time scale of
kick in is intermediate and it goes up
to about the same level as the at Birth
intervention that birth intervention
takes about a generation to kick in and
then goes up here in all cases it's
restricted to a less than four percent
in the real magnitude difference between
the control and the the intervened
epidemic so the take-home messages
you're going to have to start hitting
all three age groups simultaneously to
get a quick effect you're going to have
to do it for a very long time to get
this four percent reduction in total
prevalence so I think that disappoints
most people we've seen results from
another model that doesn't use this
technique uses a deterministic model and
gets almost exactly the same results so
we think this is in the ballpark of the
right the right numbers
somewhere in between your type of data
and yes if so how are the drug companies
are pressing that just kind of like the
relational database drug companies have
another challenge the data management
procedures used by drug companies are
mandated by things like the FDA and the
EU in other words a certified drug you
have to adhere to a certain set of
procedures and and principles basically
and so they they have a very well worked
out a way of managing data basically
it's very simple what they do the kinds
of data that they deal with are much
simpler essentially they take a
population they define everybody at the
beginning they follow those same people
for a relatively short period of time
they give some of them the drug they
give some of them a placebo and they
just follow them up and they don't care
about anything basically except what
happens basically the illness that
they're trying to intervene on so the
structure of the data are simpler and
the way that they're managed is pretty
its prescribed by these regulatory
bodies so the problems that they face
basically are how do we efficiently
manage the data and meet the criteria
set forth by the regulators our little
system that we want to put together
needs to meet those regulatory mandates
as well because a lot of the studies
that are being planned in these DSS
sites are drug trials so when we made
that we may not actually do the drug
trial but the drugs i will use our data
as part of the data that they generate
and so we have to comply so that we can
participate in those things so yeah
they do both they manage it in in
relational databases although access is
expressly prohibited because of the fact
that it its indexes can and do corrupt
and it doesn't give you any feedback
about that and then it literally
generates totally random stuff and it's
impossible to tell what's real and
what's what's not real at that point
both foxpro in and access we'll do that
so those so basically they specify which
database management systems you can use
and then they give you a format for the
data and then they give you a procedure
for how to get it in how to log it how
to correct it how to document it and how
to analyze it so it's completely can
thing 2000 how do you deal with that or
is that why you're my katey that's why
we're migrating well there's two reasons
to migrate to sequel that that problem
doesn't exist the size limitations of
access are another big problem and then
transaction logging and access basically
doesn't exist well it's kind of there
but kind of not there the multi user
experience with access is not a good one
so yeah those are the reasons okay so
those simulations that we just saw were
done in Access what you saw was an
average of three stochastic simulations
per line and each of them pretty much
maxed out access I think he would run a
simulation in excess actually hey whats
up whats robos which
the road the tables are the ones that I
just showed you pretty much you say for
instance you want to model def you have
a probability of dying at each age for
each sex modulated by your HIV status
and maybe some other risk factor you
just chunk the person through life one
month at a time if they're still alive
you expose them to the probability of
dying that is associated with their age
and their sex and their HIV status you
generate a random number you compare it
to the probability of dying if the
number is less than that probability you
killing no you get a simulation the
question is how you interpret that as a
series of tables and access that's is
each row a person there's a table with
people there's another table with unions
is another table with links between
those so in other words you generate you
people and add them to the people table
when they get to the right age to marry
you expose them to the risk of getting
married when they actually do get
married you generate a new Union in the
Union table and you you make a couple
links that link them to the the Union
then you as time goes by that Union ages
you let them have sex they have a kid
you link that kid to that Union too and
you put the new kid in the database in
the people table and essentially for all
of the events that you want to model you
use that same strategy and as you as you
need more entities you add another table
to keep track of those entities it was
actually through doing the dies in
addition for example is an additional
row or is that a person status is now
changed yet which means you lose their
head their past no you have a record in
the people table which includes the date
of birth the date of death if they died
and some control value if they're still
alive even null or something that you've
agreed upon doesn't pick any example
that happens more than once in life say
a birth birth or sex or whatever yeah so
for births you is a table in there which
holds all the fertility events for women
birth is a fertility event basically a
woman's reproductive cycle starts with
being
virchow she has sex until she conceives
if she's not contraceptive when she
concedes she can just stayed up until
she has a miscarriage and abortion or a
birth after birth she can either not
breastfeed or she can breastfeed for a
period of time stop breastfeeding
recover from all of that become fertile
again and go through that cycle many
times so you just record those events
all of those events that mark boundaries
in that cycle in one table link those
events to the woman and to the Union and
to the pregnancy which you also record
it's not too bad I mean basically the
same database that you would use to
record all of this stuff empirically on
a real population you use exactly the
same database and you write update
queries that generate the data instead
of just capturing it the big difference
is you've got all these parameters for
our eyes tables that are the probability
of these events whereas in the real
world you just let write those
probabilities right so the empirical
procedure is go out collect the data
storage analyze it to generate the
probabilities that you then relate to
whatever you just reverse the process
exactly to simulate the data and that's
exactly my mental progression in doing
this first I've collected data and then
I thought it might be easier to generate
it and in that way study all of the the
ways that things can interact okay so
let's stop there you want C to estimate
it'll take another 10 to 10 minutes okay
old people okay see you then so we're
gonna we'll just go through quickly ah
impact of it just you impact of HIV on
the elderly in Africa so the questions
here are how does HIV changes structure
the population which the older people
are living are the significant impacts
on the sex ratio what happens to the
dependency ratio how many orphans are
graded and then how many of these old
guys are left around to look after them
so we run five different scenarios no
HIV as a control epidemic untreated HIV
to look at the impact of the epidemic
itself and in three different treatments
in
Ariel's a behavioral treatment and
antiretroviral treatment and a combined
treatment we run each of these starting
in your 31 of an epidemic do three
simulations each and average them so
first we're gonna look at the trend in
the annual proportional growth of the
population these three lines are male
female and both again simulated time
here years 1 through 40 and annual
percentage growth on that axis
population and II this is under no HIV
you don't have a essentially a death
pass and the population growth between
three and four that's right okay and it
just stays that way I've simulated about
2,000 years before this so this is a
completely stable population and as a
stable growth rate so it's just that
great of four percent a year over five
years you oh yeah yeah population grows
very rapidly stable is disabled rate of
change no it's a stable age structure
that's a wheen it's stable age
structures stable marriage structures
all of the internal components of the
modulation abortions of components in
the population or relative is you that's
right precisely but the actual total
size is growing around a girl here's
what happened when you add an H of the
epidemic Lee the red line is the female
prevalence blue line is the male
prevalence and you can see that the
population growth rate begins to decline
after about 10 12 years when people
start dying and declines right down to
zero or thereabouts-- maybe slightly
below disappear right you're on the
track to get total annihilation you're
on the echo go clean out an entire
nation even go online this is an
epidemic which is very similar in
magnitude to the epidemics in Botswana
the Sioux to Zimbabwe and Swaziland
right now and they actually are getting
down to near zero growth rate right now
and if the population can't stay below
zero very long
probably about three four generations
okay so we're going 80 here 80 hundred
years hundred fifty years is probably I
mean it's effectively gone okay that
happening population sis or it just
disappeared yeah so big problem so this
is the overall big problem is that just
the raw size of your population you know
could stabilize but could actually
shrink and if it shrinks are very long
you know that's doomed okay so what
happens when you intervene with a
behavioral intervention and what this
does removes all of the extramarital
relationships so all of the extramarital
this isn't something this practical just
assuming we to create st. that's right
assuming overnight we could make
everybody into a saint what would happen
and the the motivation here is to see
what in general what kinds of things
happen and will be the biggest magnitude
of an effect knowing that in reality you
may not be able to do this at all this
is a boundary condition so you would get
an immediate reduction in prevalence
this is because you don't create as many
new cases but the cases that exist keep
dying and you have a very bad negative
effect on the growth rate because not
only do you prevent the transmissions
but you prevent the conceptions as well
so this is a big disaster this kind of
spike in the negative direction on the
growth rate quickly use are highly
resistant to this they'll never accept
it so that never happened well in places
that Uganda they they've done some of it
yet they've been able to get people to
change their behavior not everybody but
probably fifteen twenty percent of the
population maybe even more that
literally not engaging and
extracurricular it's probably mostly
changing the way you engage in a
curriculum it's condoms and it's also
sequential monogamy rather than
concurrence yeah
so that's so you can whittle you can do
something that approximates that which
is not bad and that's a very good
intervention it really slows down the
production of new HIV positive people
surreal Menard serial monogamy using a
condom having fewer extra partners all
right here's the HIV antiretroviral
treatment has a totally different kind
of effect prevalence actually goes up
probably the more people you get
infected right because there's more
people walking around to infect people
live longer in an infected state they
feel better they have a lot of sex even
though their viral load is suppressed
the fact that they live so much longer
have so much so many more contacts more
frequency right effective rate equal or
greater right exactly and in this case
slightly greater at the same time you
defer mortality so you stop people dying
right now they're going to die 10 years
later 15 years later but at least for
the moment they're not dying so the
growth rate rebounds right away and then
starts to come down again because that
deferment starts to wear off and if we
if we simulate another bunch of years I
haven't done it yet but I'm expecting
this to mirror you know just do that
again yeah a reset of maybe in 10 years
here 10 to 15 years eyes you a decade it
buys you about a decade and that's
literally all it does it's a
perturbation that resets for a decade
and then slowly relax us back to where
you were that's at the covert 10 years
behind in ages an identical behave right
this is not going to happen in general
however it's I think it's an
illustrative to a lot of people to see
that this really is just a reset that
the antiretroviral thing is not a silver
bullet at all it just buys you 10 years
and then in in the absence of anything
else you go back to where you were so
people really push it but it's got a
very limited time horizon an individual
solution is format as an individual
solution it's great i mean if i were HIV
positive i would definitely want this
it's so with any other rational this
yeah so from a humanitarian point of
view yeah you definitely you have to do
it but if you're looking if you're
looking at the population level you've
got to be aware that in the absence of
doing something else you're going to
have to start over again in ten years so
here's what happens when you do both of
them it's very nice you get a gradual
fall-off in prevalence and you get a
little a little wiggle in the growth
rate and then it stabilizes that about
1% so the take home message here is that
for the growth rate you don't want to do
one or the other neither of them are
great but together they're they're
excellent seeing here is modest
flattening and it isn't it obviously in
India in incidents and then the
population growth well I mean I guess
the difference is to be measured from
the negative five percent that you rec'd
or not look down from freedom that's
right yeah basically what we this is
still not great we're still not at four
percent although some people would argue
that we needed to get down for four
percent anyway this four percent is is
unsustainable I mean you double every I
forget what it is in a short period of
time so four percent growth is not what
you want you probably want something
that's close to zero but on the plus
side and so this is not too bad so they
were at four percent and they did not do
them the Malthus that we're moderating
the works and grocery four percent
growth rate is the Malthus thing the
four percent growth rate is yeah they
were definitely on the way what happened
is that long into the pass they were you
know near zero because of infectious
disease essentially canceling out high
fertility yeah
so medical care and missionaries over
the first part of the 20th century
brought them up to four percent because
that affected mortality but didn't do
much to affect fertility especially
their Catholic missionaries so people
are having about eight nine kids per
woman that survived well and in the past
and so that's out of about twelve
pregnancies in the past they had to 12
pregnancies in had you know two or three
kids that survived so what is the
medical impact of a dozen pregnancies
though that alone must have an enormous
help on just someone didn't that have
had 18 or 20 they're very tough people
and is a serious selection effect if you
manage to survive the reproductive years
five or six the next twelve are really a
while huh it's a different it's a
different regime yeah okay here we've
got trends in the percent of all
children who are orphans so these are
kids 0 to 15 so 15 is the cutoff so in a
normal population this normal population
high growth which means high fertility
high mortality oops no HIV about 5% of
the children are maternal orphans sorry
paternal about two and a half or
maternal and nobody is a dual orphan and
if you think well approximately know
what error yes it's but you can see it
hugs the the zero line and if you think
about that your likelihood of dying as
an adult before you become an older
adult it's very low and we take the
joint probability of that happening to
people it's almost nothing so dual
orphans in a regular regime essentially
don't exist unless you have a cause of
death which correlates the risk for the
the two parents car car accidents or war
and HIV
so HIV is one of them and the reason
that the orphan story is such a big deal
with HIV is not because it creates
singlet orphans but because it creates
these huge number of dual orphans okay
so that's what happens this is
prevalence this is the orphans the
orphan scale is over here so we wind up
with roughly twenty percent of kids 0-15
being dual orphans after 40 years so
that's a major societal problem in and
of itself okay here's what happens with
the behavioral intervention again it's a
quick drop off in prevalence continued
increase in the percent orphaned and
that's because it doesn't affect
mortality mortalities driving the
orphanhood question okay the problem is
is just the infection not mortality
prevalence is if the proportion of the
population that they should be positive
with this behavioral intervention you
stop creating new cases or at least you
drastically diminish the number of new
cases being created aration really it
takes a bug to recover right okay this
impact is going to take this is going to
take from the time of intervention yeah
about a generation maybe even a little
bit more generation and a half to get
back down to normal with an immediate
hundred percent sainthood rate here's
what happens with the antiretroviral
this is a very happy story you get the
mortality deferment your story I guess
it gets them out of childhood right this
gets them out of childhood which is a
great thing but past the ten years of
the 15 years when that wears off the new
kids are going to be orphans you're
going to get exactly the same thing
right this is this curve is going to go
like this and then well actually like
this it's going to stay like that right
okay when you put the two interventions
together again you get the nice story
you get this gradual decrease in
prevalence he gives us immediate
decrease in the orphan hood and it's a
nice
here's the more complicated thing and
when I talk to demographers I highlight
the fact that this question can only be
addressed with this kind of model what
we want to do here is track the
genealogy so we want to track the
relationships between grandparents their
children and their children were the
grandparents of the sorry the
grandchildren of the grandparent
generation so we need to have individual
links between individual people in order
to study the relationship between
grandparents and their grandchildren we
can't do this with a deterministic
compartmental model that just loves
everybody into one cell at each age okay
so here we have trains in the number
percent of adults who are 15 older with
surviving grandchildren but no surviving
children so these are older adults who
have lost all of their own children but
still have grandchildren surviving who
they may have to look after these two
lines are the raw numbers of older women
and men these lines along the bottom are
the number of them who are in this skip
generation household configuration and
the percent and you can see that in a
normal situation no HIV these numbers
are very low and very stable even though
the total number of older adults is
increasing as it should be this is what
happens in an untreated HIV epidemic two
things happen the total number of older
older adults plateaus and then actually
diminishes so the size of the older
adult population decreases this
correlates to that negative growth rate
earlier adults who would have aged into
seniority or dead that's right okay it's
not because there are able body middle
aged people who are no longer in
existence and their absence has an
impact on senior survivability not in
this month let a little model bad link
but that's something that we need to
take into account which is why this is
probably a conservative
estimate of the problem there's two
things that haven't done here haven't
modeled the impact on the mortality of
orphans orphans are at a much much
higher risk of dying in and out right
themselves just because they're orphans
and sore the older people because they
don't have the support of the middle
generation that sexual behavior of
organs is also different it can be very
different let's say they're not raised
any institutions at all no problem here
so they are they're subject to a
potentially all kinds of additional
street children they're homeless pretty
much qualify that a little bit these
older adults and extended family in lots
of parts of Africa are doing a lot to
take care of this problem but there are
what they call child headed households
which are essentially you know kids who
are on their own completely and there
are huge numbers of street kids in most
urban areas who are you know dual
orphans who didn't have anywhere to go
yeah grandma and grandpa may not be
there grandma grandpa may not be there
and your aunts and uncles probably
aren't there if your parents died
because they share some you know a lot
of that risk as well so here we have the
number sorry the overall number
decreasing and here the number of them
in this Kip generation configuration
increasing this increase starts at
around the same time that this decrease
starts and the ratio of this to this and
that to that is the fraction of those
older adults who are in this condition
and you can see that percent goes go to
skyrockets gets up to twenty percent for
women up to fifteen percent or twelve
and a half percent for men the
difference here is that men can produce
new kids over a wider age range in fact
almost until they die so it's just
simply harder to get rid of all of the
children of a man of a man because some
of them are young enough to have not
died yet ok so the behavioral
intervention
the behavioral intervention has no
effect because it's not affecting
mortality and this situation is entirely
driven by mortality the antiretroviral
has a big effect it affects mortality it
defers the thing by ten years so you get
when you combine them the effect of the
antiretroviral intervention and all the
problem is here that the behavioral
intervention will kick in later because
it's going to reduce the overall
prevalence and change change this
transition right here as time goes by in
the first eight years but it actually
starts at the moment the other way
dimension and I haven't seen her now you
know we we are doing these these
simulations and access 97 they take
forever so we did we did while i did for
and i was doing it on a laptop i did
these while i was in south africa and i
just didn't have access to anything so
what we really want to do we can start
them up again and do another 40 years
and see that so in this case again you
essentially have to hit the population
with both kinds of interventions at the
same time even though you don't see any
benefit from the behavioral intervention
for a generation a perhaps later you can
comment about what houses for an
effective behavioral intervention I mean
given i would i would like to know what
would it take in uganda to change fuel
serial monogamy on what you've got as an
interesting case what it takes it
appears is a concerted determined
long-term multi-dimensional intervention
so you get messages from the president
that say HIV is real HIV is a threat to
our country you need to pay attention to
what's going on with HIV you get
information over the radio that tells
you what HIV is how it works and what to
do about it you get condoms from your
clinic you get condoms from your school
you get community health care nurses who
come to your home and tell you what's
going on in every prenatal care regiment
you insert an HIV prevention package so
that young women become aware as soon as
possible about the situation
you roll out things increase in primary
school secondary schools you enroll
churches NGOs multilaterals wh 0 un aids
all these people to do what they can
simultaneously and keep it going for
about a decade hmm okay so it seems to
me that the main impact then is they use
the condom message it's the ABC it's
what they call it abstinence be faithful
and condom as in who the right thing but
since you're not going to write yeah
there are people there are few people
who'll do the right thing a lot of other
people who will do the right thing some
of the time and then protect themselves
the rest of the time and then there are
people who are impervious but it appears
that most people are pervious to one
extent or another consider you've got
two chances right I mean I attentively
anyway pending on the certain gender
politics both the male to female might
even want to bring protection into the
integration that's right so you've got
some chance you've got some chance and
actually Uganda started this message
sometime in the early 90s and they are
the only country in Africa that has
clearly gone through a transition in the
epidemic and prevalence has been falling
for five or six years and it's down to
three four percent remove the condom has
a mechanism for engagement with this are
there any effective protein adriel
approaches having actually I mean yes is
there any if I take the condom off the
table what's left not much not much not
much so the single Magic Bullet really
is the single Magic Bullet really is
it's educating people to change their
behavior which includes using a condom
it really isn't sudden without issue
didn't know doesn't work where it goes
because condoms the rest of africa is
saturated with condoms the rest of that
pretty much everyone that is the same in
terms of
econo yes pretty much I mean if you go
anywhere in southern Africa you it will
take you 10 seconds to find a condom
just about anywhere you are I mean there
are there are billions of condoms in
Africa that people don't use them though
people do not use yes that's the thing
just making them available and just
teaching people how to use them is not
enough people have to be willing to use
them people have to you know bring them
to the interaction people's partners
have to be accepting of people wanting
to use for existing or existing the
thing about the thing about the gender
politics often is that you know you're a
woman and you insist on the guy using a
condom you just it suggests all kinds of
things that the guys you know not
interested in hearing yeah and it's not
going to be what you're saying in Uganda
they have seemed to attract not only
availability but the motivation yeah the
motivation is the key and the motivation
and you would argue is simply repeated
messages from authority figures
insisting on the use is enough over time
to actually change that behavior right
coming from everywhere with no
hesitation no qualification know
anything the only institution in Uganda
that I know of that has really not
cooperated as the the upper realms of
the Catholic Church who have actually
preach an anti condom message but it's
been swamped apparently by the rest of
it so given that we the United States
are not in the same matrix of conditions
pi have essentially take makan them off
the table as a legitimate I mean do not
have unequivocal uniform regular
promotion of the condom as a solution
given that we have Android 4 Bibles we
have hospitals we've got you know a
certain number of other things that sort
of contain this what's our future the
epidemic here is just totally different
it's in advocates a heterosexual
generalized epidemic it's her meets
every part of the population here we're
pretty much restricted to the homosexual
population
certain small parts of the IV drug using
population and the real the real issue
now is the fact that it's becoming in a
small way a heterosexual epidemic in in
the black population in the impoverished
segment of the black population and
predominantly young women so that's
where the real issue is right now what's
interesting here is it not only has the
condom kind of somehow been marginalized
but there's a behavioral backlash of
some sort going on in the homosexual
community is this kind of behavioral
this inhibition though I'm on a RTS I'm
not hard I'm feeling good you know what
the hell there are people who are
actively kind of rebelling and
proactively acquiring the virus there
are people who are yeah just purposely
not using a condom so that they can pass
it or get it but there's just there's a
whole ski there's a whole kind of a way
of interesting behavior going on which
has had a pretty substantial impact on
the incidence in the gay community over
the last five six years but the but it's
still contained to the homosexual
community it's not really breaking out
where it's breaking out is in the black
population and what's interesting is
that it that epidemic seems to be
showing a lot of signs of being similar
to the African epidemic including
people's attitudes towards the
interventions suspicions a lot of race
politics a lot of gender politics a lot
of yeah just unwillingness to take
information from other groups of people
and utilize it so within perceives
magnitude of risk is when people's
perceptions are totally off but is this
is what I'm suggesting
one of the interventions is the
perception of risk and and the
likelihood of risk and the relative
magnitude of that risk versus others
that are more likely so if you think
that other more violent ends of life are
more probable yes I mean you're you're
expected basically you're internalized
life expectancy seems to be a play a key
role in all kinds of risky behavior I
mean if you're only looking at a five
year time horizon whether or not you
have whether or not you're hiv-positive
doesn't matter yeah I me if you're
looking at a 15 year time horizon it may
matter but may not there's a great touch
and I don't know if you pick up the
Battlestar Galactica bug but it's the is
perhaps one of the greatest shows on
television today in it the remnants of
humanity are hard up against the wall
they may not survive the medical the
chief medical officer is chain smoker
huh and it just kind of tries home be
you know none of us are going to be here
for much longer tightly as yeah I'm here
to keep you alive but you know it's
basic you know not for long yeah that's
like smoking interventions for the above
75 set doesn't work okay fascinating
stuff so yeah the u.s. i don't know the
thing about the white kind of
generalized white population is that I
think we were all indoctrinated while
these dials on them will be hunger in
high school that you know just don't
have sex because you're going to get
AIDS and you're going to die and it's
just not true at all I mean your your
probability per per intercourse act is
roughly one in a thousand with an HIV
positive person and your likelihood here
of actually meeting an hiv-positive
white person unless they are gay or IV
drug using is I mean diminishing to
nothing so you've got a one in a million
of meeting the person and then a one and
A Thousand actually getting it from them
right but describe the public health
strategy here was I think and I don't
know this for a fact
my supposition was to intentionally
distort that risk message I'm scared of
out everybody so that they wouldn't
have sex and it worked they work
perfectly yes but I think an argument I
think would be if you compartmentalize
the risk you get into not only the
gender politics for the various sub
community politics of essentially bill
defying them because they have higher
incidents yeah you have to be yeah and
then you work against yourself because
that confirms the you know the already
negative perception that that community
had of you and your intervention yeah I
can see the challenges there are the
relative rates of all the other
nastiness that you can get out there is
it one in a thousand for everything STDs
no other STDs are much more
transmissible okay so come to like one
in five he works the herpes the syphilis
all of that you can get you can get it
the other thing is that if you have one
of those your probability getting or
transmitting HIV goes way up from like
one in a thousand to 150 oh really so it
really reduces your resistance two in
fact well what those all of those things
what they do is they they change the
physiology of the mucosal surfaces and
they often lead to open sores and that's
just a direct route opens the door yeah
well I think we should all clap now uh
Sam this is really remarkable work I
very much appreciate you taking the time
I think from the brief comment you got
you may have captured some of the
reaction locals they'll have which is
that's not big data on the other hand I
hear your point it is big but yeah it's
almost a nice response to get because
they're like oh that's not a big problem
we can do that yeah but I think you
pointed to about the real obstacles and
said you spent ten years in the UK
trying to fill
system and pulled out with the tail
between your legs yeah I think the
challenge is one of you identified and
that is taking expertise that is
existent yeah but is lock up behind you
know the highways wall and bringing it
to what tasted a public low-wage
environment you do raise an important
point the high-quality sequel developer
is rare and expensive because it's a
real skill it's not easy to get that
school yes it's not it's not easy I
didn't take your point go and I think
this is sort of like the infection
charts that you've shown what's it going
to take to have an intervention that's
going to cure this problem and I would
argue that the only real solution is to
grow a crop and you have to start with
the undergrad master students right now
and so what you've done is I think the
best haverhill intervention because
frankly I don't really think that NSF is
going to rise to your head of market
wage oh they're not going to rise all
the way up there in Iraq okay I'm hoping
to their farm or I'm hoping that we can
convince well put it this way the big
fund is on there NH eats larger private
foundations multilaterals are beginning
to realize
they spent all this money to come I data
that they can't use them and they
correctly identify the fact that pig
bottom line is hidden management skills
and they are they are being very
motivated a foundation i will say that
then you have this confluence both
goomy's and the method yeah I mean
history 80s on the Asian actually true
every clues are these data processing
side of things yeah he did that
foundation actually requested this
repulsive was so great so like I said
we're kind of managers necessary but we
are going to get a very good shot
no some are because there are people
here for example who specialize in
transforming destroyed schema into a
common reference boy we would elect it's
an open area of research in that it's
difficult is it about me but this is the
kind of thing that is a you know an
active area researcher so schema
macrumors how our lives of people who
specialized and schema mapping
absolutely really oh yeah because it's a
difficult thing to do it's necessary so
what will bring the AV part of our show
to an end I think what this does point
to is a points for future engagement and
I think schema mapping is hell our
number one goal for you and that I think
we're going to now look to try to set
you up with the right people these hours
and a combination of ms are in the side
of the lake and gates foundation on that
side and UW a pop we should be over
making them this could be the place make
this happen I agree completely okay okay
so much thank you